If you want a life of purpose,
Begin by inverting the notion
that everything happens for a reason.
All your efforts,
personal,
professional,
carnal...
You must be willing to make the hard choices,
do the unpleasant things,
risk your most valuable assets.
Because nothing worthwhile
is ever achieved without sacrifice.
Now that you're on the brink of greatness
are there still limitations to
what you'd be willing to sacrifice?
In this case, a night alone with your husband.
Would that be an acceptable condition
of a firm offer to finance your company?
What do you really know about Anne Montgomery?
Things could get dangerous very quickly.
Things have always been dangerous.
Sean!
What is it that you imagine I did him?
I made a mistake.
But I do not deserve to lose everything.
Regret is all I've felt since the moment we met.
How many more people need to be hurt
before you get what you want?
You're more committed than you realize.
The worst kind of victim
is the one that chooses to create another.
I am no one's victim.
Are you absolutely certain
this is the choice you want to make?
I'm not what you think I am.
Maybe not, but I'm beginning to see potential.
True success comes at any cost.